et bien maintenant les cherry on va
faire une dictée par la nasa avait
interrompu reprise ou le sortilège hedge
funds forte touche une poigne un stylo à
bille sur la b devant vous celui qui
peut le plus de fautes devra porter un
bonnet d'âne pendant toute l'émission
est un extrait de la dictée de bernard
pivot de 2012 en france
attention aux noms ces choses tu peux me
dire qu les chéris c'est parti là là là
là ils adorent ça et là ce sont attisées
là ce sont anne arabe chez moi je ne
sortais pas sortir dîner naturel de
clocher là ce sont attisées
d'inénarrables querelles de clochers et
se sont chamaillés jamaïque et deux de
plus oui chamailler pour des peccadilles
pour des peccadilles puis rabibocher je
sais que ça ira bibeau chez puis
rabibocher rabibocher qui sait que ça la
fout de quoi ce sont ces voix là la saq
et même dans les bouchons qui twitte
vous êtes vous c'est sur fond du seau la
fête foraine ou sept ans levi témoin
accueilli rabibocher nombre de
générations
non mais c'est une phrase no hero 2
générations d'aptilon qu'en d'autres
temps
pardon tu en auras soit un des
générations pourquoi on n'est pas même
site vous dites vous qu'en d'autres
temps
se sont retrouvés une dentellière
d'autres dites vous qu'en d'autres temps
6 on retrouve ici son assistance au
sahara sauf s'ils sont si sont retrouvés
ici on retrouve et j'en profite pour
dire aux téléspectateurs que jusqu après
il y aura une caméra cachée de greg dit
oui
ah oui et non on promet un magnifique on
peut les voir ses manières son procès
unique en d'autres temps ci sont
retrouvés une dentellière dans une
dentellière une dent te dis oui aux
reflets dit vous qu'en d'autres temps ci
sont retrouvés une dentellière aux
reflets chocolat
hahaha
je voudrais
hamon
ça
[Applaudissements]
je
concession
composé sur moi et mal
non
je n'ose pas l'outil qui compte pour moi
je la veux
[Musique]
on le veut
et